siamo su socket che a noi già partite ok
siamo su gioco che è già partito c'è un
quadro della madonna bellissimo bar come
la madonna ma c'è questi quadri salò ma
cosa vi rappresenta da rockol di aspetto
che c'è una cappa non la cappa da cucina
la cappa può essere qua cioè sta pure la
carta igienica nel caso ci caliamo
addosso era tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo nuovo blog in casa di non so ki
laviamo la videocamera perché ne sposano
una guardiana svezia e cascate pure la
cosa mi stava allora vediamo se riesco a
fare qualcosa che avevano capito devo
fare
a parte fissare quadri bellissimi a sia
bretta st portale sgrò c'è una p sul
muro prima c'era una cappa adesso c'è
una pipì capua sarebbe paperinik non so
se effettivamente york langer pizzeria
non è proprio pizza napoletana questo
secondo me però c'è un piano di sopra
unexpected questa madonna che figo che
mi resta casa o se dietro altre scritte
tipo da sotto no c'ho un libro permesso
mi servirebbe più di piper tradurre sta
roba prova un gioco svedese c'è la cosa
più strana li abbiamo visti anche perché
non so nulla di al libro di prima perche
mi sono spaventato da soli giorgi
colossi a giorgio e per quelle per
quello da dire me ne sto andando a e la
porta chiusa non si apre 9 ne vado a
prendere le chiavi in credo che sia
quartu boxes am campa veri che sono i
simboli che trovate in gp mk pmk quelli
dei simboli che ho trovato posso trovare
il modo di aprire la scatola
questa è la p3 non c'è niente qualcuno
il fatto devo trovare tutto sto casino
per aprire quella scatola legge sta cosa
non l'ho capita va bene però alla bri la
m mi manca che dia mela m non l'ho
trovata neanche prima cioè non solo
queste foto bellissime ma io devo fare
io fra pista
oddio non l'avevo visto sta a fare bello
è bello sentire di più lo zio comunque
ho trovato la scatola ho trovato anche
le cose per i kiwi ma non ho capito come
si apre quindi mi scusi lei rimarrà qua
dentro
che cacchio vuoi come ho fatto ma scusa
come o come ho fatto prima non lo
schiacciati 60 volte prima di mk va bene
ma che gli ho girati teoricamente
dovrebbe essersi aperta press fainas
compito qua c'è un'altra maniglia va
bene barbato qua ho trovato una maniglia
lo zio non vado vado zio tranquillo c'è
uno chiuso la dentro che continua a poi
o cristo sa essere molto appannato ci
sono le sta svendendo nessuno può
aiutare comunque ho aperto il basement
che è bello allegro anche comunque suo
nonno e paranoico però non credo che sia
il miglior modo se la scommessa ma la
noia sta cosa qua sta consolando al
soffitto va bene un idraulico quando
avete tempo utri milan gratis plan
evacuation plan sappiamo un po di parole
di svedese un emergency exit che però è
chiusa da dei divani quindi vado a
destra ma vaffan gulas ore da che due
bus
c'è un uscita qualche chiusa però
qualcuno ha rubato fatto levites o con
la frutta è odio aiuto o meglio visto
tizio moltissimo tutto questo per
trovare una chiave di merda mi sembra un
po eccessivo posso stare qua nascosto
dalle scatole che ha può annunciare vi
manco morto lo zio non ci arrivi banco
non ti sai accovacciare te lo dico io lo
sento che dietro al muro
cioè orribile finché a destra scatola
dove dove rispettato non c'è più è
sparito lo zio lo sento lottare verso
dall'altra parte il posto è questo dove
devo trovare st chiare maledetta per una
leva cazzo studiato una leva mai sentito
via via via via vere aggiungi la società
riesce non si esce un porco del demonio
porco
addio salve priva di schema bema quello
passa in mezzo ai fedeli al divano porca
vacca aiuto da strane va a chi nei bulls
non lo so ma mi ha preso e che la cosa
non mi è piaciuta c'è un'altra leva che
devo tirare mi sapere lo tirate 2 nato
ma che roba orribile ma cuocerà semplice
la prima quella seconda ne manca una
ragazzi possibile ma come faccio a
schivarlo lo zio lo doveva
ma io aiuto ecco tirati a questa cosa
girata bene vado me ne vado bene quanto
prelevato me ne vado privato
arrivederci sono andato se n'è andato
dall'altra sarà andato dall'altra parte
va bene ne vado tirate le vele o tirate
per aprire una scatoletta di merda anzi
non l'ho già aperta però non serve dire
anche con si apre la porta di sopra sono
cosa devo fare adesso lui può sentirmi
per questo ho capito 123 a devo andare a
luce a devo avere uscita con il fondo
credo no d'allenamento raga che palle
passa attraverso i muri vediamo
marilungo demonio sto fitti debutta
questa la chiave
eccola una chiave di merda silvietto
cifra che lo so non so neanche dove
misto nascondendomi sono state comunque
è stato orribile perché non me
l'aspettavo mai prima sono andato al
demanio metto qua non mi vede nomi per
tempo si vede già scritto combi non so
cosa voglia dire i svedese
niente di buono secondo me comunque
veramente orribile sto tizio cioè
proprio per lutto culo madonna si è
fatti
passa un centro estetico quando ci hai
tempo cavalcavano tutto lei e trovai che
non ci facciamo già fatto ce l'ho fatta
e murata la porta e morata e morata del
giocatore al panino ultimi tastini si
facciamo loro sori
sono uscito dal basement ed è tutto
smith io no ragazzi orribile adesso vado
di sapere successo qualcosa
questa tratta è chiusa che aperta
don hoarding hickman quisling qui non
c'è più sapevo io non son trovato un
fusibile in compenso cinese sun yang
living me ne vado ne vado fuori dalle
palle
ho tolto fusi so anche dove mettono
perché all'inizio c'era posto
il fusibile la televisione si è spostata
in altro che comunque molto meglio
secondo me sei un internal designer se
c'è un italiano un po storto per lo sei
non attaccare serie con la colla che si
stacca piace natura morta nel basement
nicchiato tornare spaceman ben chiusa ma
solo perché sono attaccapanni che sbarra
la porta sembra fugazi che sarebbe aiuto
torniamo le basement sinergie per un
paio di palle effettivamente fatto che
non vedo niente c'è stato allaccio non
vedo niente
ecco è proprio lui
non mi sembra proprio l'uscita parco
forza giappone da spulciare vuol dire lo
googlato dire grazie per l'aiuto che mi
ha visto fuggire lui no no no no no no
no no no no
perché ma si può finire un gioco normale
ve ne prego ve ne prego
va bè ragazzi abbiamo fatto uscire
satana però almeno abbiamo spostato il
televisore in perché comunque è un pezzo
di design che non va trascurato bello
bello che so che tu un po strano ma
bello comunque spero che vi sia piaciuto
fatemi sapere se volete un altro horror
che ultimamente vi sorprenderete di
giocare horror come sempre signori
iscriviti al canale e delle ci vediamo
al prossimo vito bella regali
[Musica]